If you are not intending to listen to a panel
on social
commerce you're in the wrong place. We have
actually a
really great group of speakers here who represent
a lot of
different aspects of social commerce and so
what I wanted to
was start off by - let's start off with Brian,
at the end
there, who is one of the founders of AirBNB
and is
definitely in the anti-portfolio for floodgate.
We actually heard the pitch for AirBNB right
before they
went live in the democratic convention. Whenever
I'm asked
which company I regret not investing in, the
number one
answer for me is AirBNB. Bring on the pain.
Is it just introduction?
Yes, introduction. Tell us a little bit about
your company
and a little about your background.
Excellent. Yes, I'm Brian Chesky. I'm one
of the founders
and CEO of www.AirBNB.com. We are a community
market place
where you can list and book all sorts of unique
spaces
around the world; like to say anything from
a private
apartment to a private island. It's all sorts
of spaces from
a night to a year. We are in 10000 cities.
Travelers came last year from every country
on a plane up in
North Korea and the Congo, so we're literally
in 192
countries around the world and we really started
in New York
City. We started getting a lot of traction
about two years
ago and it has really taken off since then.
We are in about
10000 cities and this is a business that was
somewhat
serendipitously started.
I had moved up from Los Angeles to San Francisco
about three
years ago and I was with my college roommate
at the time and
we weren't able to make rent and a design
conference was
coming to San Francisco. All the hotels for
design
conference was sold out and I had originally
quit my job,
and I think I had $1000 in the bank account.
This is October 2007, so probably a really
good planning,
obviously. I get to San Francisco and I realize
rent was
$1150, so I already had enough problem right
there. We didn'
t know what to do. This conference was coming
to San
Francisco, all the hotels were sold out. We
had this idea,
why don't we create a bed & breakfast for
the conference?
That was the vision. There was no business
plan; the vision
was let's make rent for the month of October.
That was the
business plan basically. I told Joe, "We don't
have any
furniture so we can't create a bed & breakfast."
He said, "
Brian, we have a few airbeds in the closet."
We blew up some
airbeds, we called it the Air Bed & Breakfast.
It was a
temporary bed & breakfast, we ended up making
I think $1000
by hosting a bunch of people that week and
that was supposed
to be it.
Over the next few months, people started saying
they'd love
to use us and that would be awesome if they
could go
somewhere and use it. I'm not going to go
into full story
except to say that we started our business
to solve our own
problem and our own problem was to make rent
and we'd like
to say what started as an airbed in the living
room is now
spread to 10000 cities around the world.
That's Gregg.
Hi, Gregg Fence. I'm the Chief Marketing Officer
of One
Kings Lane. I joined late last year after
10 years at E-Bay
and a wide variety of ten years in marketing,
general
management and products, so quite a few things
happened over
the course of the 2000s and prior to that.
I worked at Coca-Cola and kind of classic
marketing, classic
brand management. We are a company founded
just about two
years ago by Susan Feldman and Alison Pinkus,
really focused
on the home and living space and we are just
laser-focused
on driving deep and delivering on the consumer
needs and
also the industry needs in a very fragmented
industry that's
been very challenged with the downturn of
the economy.
We're grounded in sales events but you've
probably seen
overtime that we're growing into new forms
e-commerce;
better ways to serve products to our consumers
and really
delivering a great curated branded experience
in many, many
interesting ways and really trying to weave
commerce and
content together, tell an interesting story
and then attach
products around those stories which really,
I don't think,
has been done. It was sort of the promise
of the internet in
early 2000s. We're going to try to crack with
a deep focus
on home and living.
My name is Brett Garrett, Bain Capital Ventures;
which is a
venture and growth equity, investment on bank
capital. We're
deeply involved in lots of social and e-commerce
and social
e-commerce companies from LinkedIn to Rent-A-Runway
which is
a kind of a high end dress rental, the Netflix
of dresses
we'd like to call that.
The Find, which is a vertical search
for shopping. Buy With Me, which is a group
buying website
and we're looking to invest in a lot more.
I'll be representing the VC part of the room.
My name is Brett Keintz, I'm an '08 grad of
GSB and I work
with Groupon. My official title is Director
of Social. I'm
in the product management group and my background
is
primarily in social, so in building apps on
the Facebook
platform, on the Twitter platform and at Groupon,
I do a lot
of new product development.
And this is our last. I'm Ann Miura-Ko, I'll
be moderating
this session. I am an investor at Floodgate
and I've
invested in a couple of social commerce companies.
In our
portfolio, we have a company called Chegg,
which is textbook
rentals and I'm also on the board of ModCloth,
which is a
good example of social commerce in the fashion
space.
I wanted to kick off this conversation. There
is a lot of
different opinions as to what social commerce
means.
Everyone talks about social commerce but they
seem to be
talking about it in a lot of different ways.
I wanted to go
down this group and just tell us from your
perspective what
are some of the defining characteristics of
social commerce.
Social commerce is definitely a big buzzword
these days. I
think the way I think about it
and the way I think we think
about at Groupon is a lot of the way that
Facebook defines
sort of this concept of a graph, a lot of
people will say, "
You throw Facebook connect on a website and
you've got
social commerce," that's not really fundamentally
how it
works. It's not just about virality and sharing
through the
newsfeed to your friends whenever you buy
something, that's
not truly social. I think you have to figure
what your
business is and what the nodes of
[inaudible] business are.
For us, it's local businesses and consumers
and how we
connect those two through commerce, through
a transaction.
That's how I really think about social commerce
and
permissions play a big part of that. The permission
of how
you can engage with the consumer, how you
can get them to be
open to receiving messages or want to receive
these sort of
messages, that's really where Facebook has
done the best out
of anyone in enabling this two-way communication
chAnnl
between friends.
The same thing applies for local businesses.
It applies to
home manufacturers, it applies to people who
have an
apartment or an air bed and breakfast that
they want to
connect with other consumers. That's kind
of how I think
about it.
I think I would agree with that. I think in
general social
e-commerce is a pretty unyouthful label because
it is so
broad and so undefined, but I think within
it there are
really interesting businesses and there are
really
uninteresting businesses in terms what social
commerce is
and so, I think there is one social commerce
where you just
take your business and you have Facebook connect
and now
social commerce and there is another way you're
really doing
something new; you're either taking your social
activities
offline, you're facilitating going to the
Web somehow or
you're creating totally new behaviors like
AirBNB, they are
only possible because of the Web and you're
able to kind of
create a commerce platform that way with social
connections.
I think in that spectrum, I think the more
interesting ones
are the ones where you're not just sticking
some kind of
Facebook connect or some social label on something
that you'
re already doing but you're really imagining
something very
new and something that's available to do only
now because
there is a social graph that you can leverage,
so I make
that distinction.
Same opinion. I think the basics is wiring
your setup to
share is really just the basics but how we're
thinking about
things is how do consumers really start influencing
our
shelves in the realtime, how does our inventory
shift as our
consumer needs shift around that? How do we
really co-opt
our consumers into becoming our sales force,
our
merchandising team or customer support team?
How do you
incent them, how do you arm them, how do you
encourage them
authentically to go to work on your behalf
because they love
your brand?
I don't think companies have really done that
well
authentically. That's the magic word it's
scale
authentically, cost-effective and where there
has been a big
fixation for all the reasons in the Facebook
and Twitter,
because of the network effects they've created.
We're
equally as interested in the tales of social
media. Where do
enthusiasts live? The Web, the forums, the
blogs, the places
where they talk about what they love and I
think we're going
to see more folks starting to push out there
with new
technologies to really try to scale out into
the tales of
social media because of the enormous power
out there.
I think it's the early days quite honestly,
a lot of fun
stuff is going to happen over the next several
years.
I think we think of social commerce as very
distinct at
[inaudible] to be and it means breathing online
- offline.
We feel like a lot of things before AirBNB
meant bringing
offline online and we think AirBNB is very
much bringing
online offline. We are now connection millions
of people
around the world. It's actually really cool
because we can
create a world map and show which countries
we've connected
to other countries.
In America, we're connected with residents
in 90 different
countries last year. I believe Australians
are connected
with people in 60 different countries and
we can country by
country and look. If you bring those all together,
almost
every single country has been connected with
another country
on the planet minus the two countries I mentioned
and it's
very intimate. Social commerce in our sense
is very
intimate.
There is three really intimate things that
you can do online
or offline. The first thing is that you're
paying somebody
else money. A financial transaction is a very
intimate
transaction, because you're paying money.
Another thing you'
re doing is you're meeting people in real
life that you don'
t know. It's the idea of meeting somebody
in the real world
that you met on the internet; ten years ago
there was a
stigma to that, I think it's pretty accepted
today.
We're combining that with money, we're writing
a third thing
and the third thing is now you're in the home
with the
person. If you combine those three things,
that is
incredibly unique kind of intimate transaction.
I think that's a great point. I think one
of the customers
for one of our portfolio companies Zimride
said, "My life
becomes more interesting when I open my door."
I thought
that really captured this notion of what a
lot of people are
calling collaborative commerce or the sharing
economy.
What I'd love to do is dive a little more
deeply into that
concept Brian around. What is it about today
that makes this
kind of sharing and collaborative culture
possible?
We've been struggling with that in a sense.
When people hear
about our concept, it depends. I think in
2007 people heard
about our concept they thought, "Are you crazy?"
That was I
think what my mom said and lots of my friends
said. Of
course they don't say it at the time, they
say it a year
later like, "Let me tell you what I really
thought." At the
time they were really supportive, "Oh, it's
excellent." A
year ago, "I thought you were crazy."
There were things that I think had to happen
on the internet
before you could do all those kind of things.
You could
argue you had to do all those three things
in our websites
but do all those three things distinctly.
Paying other people; that happens on E-Bay.
Before E-Bay,
there was a huge stigma to doing that and
people were not
comfortable. People wouldn't buy anything
online, let alone
pay another person online, so that had to
happen.
Meeting people from the internet. 15 years
ago, even ten
years ago, there was a huge stigma. Today,
not a big deal.
And sharing space with people from online;
that happens
every day on Craigslist. Maybe you get your
roommate. A lot
of people in school or after you graduated,
you'll find
roommates on Craigslist. The average person
probably has, so
AirBNB, I think in many ways just picked all
three of those
and they converged them, so they are already
doing it but we
had to allow all these other websites to happen
first. And
then, you bring them all those unique things
together.
What about trust though? What kind of issues
do you find
with that?
I think that's one of the other reasons. I
think trust is
the currency of our marketplace and the way
our site works
is you can book space or stay with people
all over the world
and trust is the mechanism that allows that.
We allow you to
check Facebook, you can see who their friends
are. The real
key though is the reviews, the transactional
based reviews.
After you stay with somebody, you leave a
transactionally
based review.
That's a quantitative score, various things
about them and
they leave a reciprocal review. We have 24/7
customer
support and as you build this user base of
profiles with
reviews, you're basically building a trusted
community
marketplace, it's a currency that over time
- now, it's
really hard to get going because no one really
wants to be
the first person without a review to book
another person
without a review and so, there is a long story
of why we
took AirBNB took a really long time to get
going.
Now we have hundreds of thousands of reviews.
One of the new
features we're going to coming out with is
to allow you, if
you don't yet have reviews, you can self-select
and say, "I
want to stay with Stanford alumni around the
world." Maybe
you're in Tokyo; we can find you a Stanford
alumni that we
connect you to as well, so trust can come
through being
earned or it can come through affinity groups
as well.
So communities is a really important part
of that.
I feel like that's also, in some ways with
One Kings Lane,
what's really interesting is that you guys
have really
focused on one particular vertical and having
a lot of
credibility within that vertical and I just
want to dive a
little bit more deeply into that concept.
Have you guys
thought about moving into other verticals
and why did you
pick this one in particular?
Actually, we haven't. Laser focus by the founders
was
saying, "We want to drive deep and really,
truly deliver on
the needs of consumers in the home and living
category,"
versus I came from E-Bay where we sold everything
to
everybody and it's daunting, it's hard to
deliver a really
rich experience in a given category if you've
got to serve
50, 60, 70 categories. So we're very laser
focused on this
category.
In large part, because it's incredibly fragmented
on the
retail side. These folks really felt the pain
when the
economy turned down particularly the high
end of the
industry. There are brands collapsed, the
magazines
collapsed. They were looking for a solution
to sell their
goods to consumers without degrading the brand
experience
and really needed a place One Kings Lane,
just like Gill
Groupe has done in the apparel industry. They
need a place
to move their merchandise while they keep
their brand high
and really well thought of.
On the consumer side, it's challenging for
consumers as
well. You ask most consumers what their design
tastes are
and they say, "Eclectic," because they don't
know. That's
basically, "I don't know what they are." And
so what they
are looking for is people to help them, guide
them, curate,
give them a sense of how they can build things
out one at a
time, make it less intimidating, really starting
to
democratize the industry which by the way,
fashion was
democratized ten years ago, the internet really
ripped it
out in the mainstream, it didn't happen in
home. That's we'
re really looking to do is make it a whole
lot less
intimidating on the consumer side, the buyer
side and really
be a solution to the retail side which is
challenged right
now.
I'd like to dive in a little bit more into
the concept of
curation that you bring up, because it feels
like
particularly for groups like Gilt Groupe or
One Kings Lane
and I've seen this with the ModCloth; one
of the things that
develops a brand is actually point of view
as to what your
brand should be about and it's something that
differentiates
these types of e-commerce companies from what
I call
Commerce 1.0 where you're creating essentially
a database of
all the products that could be sold as in
Amazon.
It feels like there is a strong tie between
this curation
concept and social commerce. What do you think
is that tie?
I think curation is the secret sauce and we
actually as a
company, one of the first things I did when
I got there, the
founders said, "Really bring our brand to
life, articulate
it, put it on paper, dimensionalize. As we
hire new people,
we get bigger, we don't want to lose sight
of who we are and
what we're all about." That's kind of rare
for companies.
The challenge is, coming from E-Bay was not
curated, trying
to curate. That's tough. It's easier to start
with a very
tight experience and walk and walk and walk
and give more
power to the consumer, make it more social,
allow consumers
to sell to other consumers and that's what
everyone aspires
to do. It's just really hard to do tight curation
and scale.
That's the magic, when you make both of those
work.
AirBNB is doing a phenomenal job in making
them both work,
that is really the solution. And I'm biased
in I think
driving deep in categories, being very focused
on a narrow
set of consumers and segments is a winning
solution going
forward.
So to challenge that notion going on to Groupon,
you guys
have really expanded really, really fast and
it doesn't
necessarily feel like there is really a lot
of curation. How
do you think through that kind of social commerce?
Do you
want to move in a more curated direction or
do you want to
just provide offers to the masses?
The interesting thing is it may not be as
well known but we
actually do a lot of curation, so we have
an editorial staff
of probably 100 or more people that are doing
write ups on a
daily basis and that's just a lot content.
I think there is
a stat out there about how much content is
created by
editorial team and it's something like thousands
of
newspapers worth on a daily basis for every
deal that we run
in every city we are in.
Curation is something that we value fairly
highly. The trust
factor you were talking about; we are curators
of local
experiences, so we have to pick out the best
ones. We use
other review sites as well and look at what
the reputations
of those businesses are elsewhere as well
as in discussing
with them to determine just how good those
businesses are,
but at the end of the day when someone buys
a groupon, they
expect it to be a great experience and if
the local merchant
can't deliver on that because of whatever
reason; whether
it's our fault or not we suffer for that.
We try to be very careful in terms of making
sure the
merchants are ready for the onslaught of customers
they
have, making sure that they do actually provide
good
experiences, but then there is the challenge
of growth. How
do you continue to grow when you're curating
so heavily? And
I think that's just something that our business
and One
Kings Lane and we all have to deal with as
we're trying to
create a great customer experience while still
growing
massively over geographies and internationally
in both
categories.
Everyone thought that the solution to curation
was math;
algorithms that tell you to do everything
and that's where
everyone went wrong. There was no personalization
and
curation is really balancing the editorial
and the
algorithms. You've got to get both right,
that's where the
secret is going to come which is really hard
to make a math
working skill and that's why in Groupon we
say is there
balancing the both sides of the equation and
really doing
some amazing things.
I have to agree with that. I think one of
the things that I
always see in entrepreneurs is that that they
- because I
teach mostly in the engineering school a lot
of these
students come in thinking that the computers
can solve the
problems and one of the most compelling parts
of ModCloth in
particular was, there was a woman there who
really
understood the community and the customers
she was selling
to, so I think that's definitely an important
component.
Now, we've looked through three different
types of the
social commerce business. I'd love to ask
Brett, in terms of
when you think about investing in these types
of companies
then we've looked at curation, this concept
of collaborative
commerce and what makes that successful even
with these
sales sites the concept of community and how
communities
will also help these couponing sites. How
do you think about
evaluating these types of companies? What's
the most
important component for you?
There is not one component that stands out
head and
shoulders above everything else but I think
there are some
themes that we're generally very excited about.
I think the
three panelists here that are operators really
represent I
think some of those themes.
I'd say one of the biggest things we're excited
about in
terms of social e-commerce really is kind
of what Brian said
earlier, which is taking the paradigm from
bringing people
on the internet to taking people off the internet.
And so,
AirBNB in a lot of ways I think was unlikely
inaugural
company to do this, because of all the miracles
I think
Brian had to overcome, but we're seeing lots
more
marketplaces that the internet enables social
commerce on
but is not really on the internet in the traditional
way.
Some examples of that are a company called
thredUP based in
San Francisco, which enables parents to send
each other
boxes of clothes when their kids outgrow them,
so it's
taking a very social practice that happened
long before
there was an internet. People would say, "My
2-year old, 5-
year old, 7-year old just outgrew these clothes,
I'm not
waiting for an in-law or someone else to give
them to you,"
but now the internet empowers this practice
and you can
share with only people who are in certain
groups or
everybody and there is these platforms now
where the
internet is touching that a little bit, in
a sense that it's
not happening on the internet, it's happening
in people's
houses where they pack all the boxes and print
out the
labels, but internet is ubiquitously letting
this happen.
Things like thredUP, things like Getaround
or RelayRides,
which are kind of like the AirBNB for cars
so there is this
collaborative consumption again through the
mobile device,
allowing the internet to go through this whole
platform and
enable us to help enough people go in a web
page in surfing
around and have a social experience. I think
those type of
marketplaces that are inherently social, that
are happening
offline are really interesting from an investment
perspective, because A) They are marketplaces
that are
really stable and hard to dislodge overtime
but B) Taking
behavior that is just really has been happening
for a long
time and making it more powerful and more
extensible in lots
of ways.
I think that's one things that's been really
exciting. There
is other themes too but I think that's kind
of the next
generation of social e-commerce.
I saw Brian, you were smiling when he was
saying AirBNB of
something and that means you really know you've
made it when
people are saying that.
When we launched we said we were the E-Bay
of space. It's
funny how we came up with that name. We did
"why common air"
it doesn't like to call itself incubation,
I guess you could
say it's just kind of seed program where they
give you
$20000 and it has a bit of collegial field;
there is
typically 20 or 30 companies that will enter
twice a year to
this 12-week program. Every week there is
a notable speaker
and this all leads to this final day called
"Demo Day".
Leading up to Demo Day, we were trying to
explain what we
were and I remember Paul Graham, people at
the time couldn't
get their heads around if there was a real
business here and
there is notably like couch surfing. A lot
of people
originally thought we were couch surfing.
Today we have a
lot of homes, we have like really big spaces,
we have
castles, we even have cars and boats and all
sorts of
spaces, but back then it was mostly bedrooms
and airbeds in
living rooms. Paul Graham says, "You should
say you're the
E-Bay of space," because E-Bay was a marketplace.
They were
really big, they were a billion dollar company
and never
rent space.
We were so matter of fact and like, "Yeah,
we're the E-Bay
of space," and at the time, I don't know if
we really could
say we were because we were pretty much the
E-Bay of
bedrooms but now we really have moved into
any type of
unique space and the thing we'd like to say
is E-Bay can
become a billion dollar company but monetizing
stuff in your
home, how big could a company be if they monetized
the home,
which is basically 25% of the annual assets
and the
backyard, the front yard, all that kind of
space and one
other thing maybe I'll say and this is to
follow up Brett's
point was, I think in many ways social commerce
is the way
things always were and the way that they will
be and I think
it was kind of post World War too, there was
this period of
maybe 60 years, at least in our space, where
it wasn't like
that and the story goes like this:
We came up with a concept; I told my mom about
it. My mom is
59 years old, baby boomer, and she thought
we were crazy and
most of her friends probably thought we were
crazy. And I
told my late grandfather about it. My grandfather
grew up in
Great Depression and he said, "Of course,"
and I go, "What
do you mean, of course?" He had done this
when he was
growing up. Of course there was no internet,
but there
weren't modern hotels like we know today.
People would stay
in bed and breakfasts and inns or in private
residences. The
word "Southern hospitality" really means like
taking people
into your homes and they have that symbol,
a pineapple,
which is a symbol of hospitality. They used
to have
pineapples at the ends of your bed.
In other words, this is how people have been
traveling since
the biblical times. A hotel 100 years ago
looked like a bed
and breakfast today; a bed and breakfast 100
years ago
looked like AirBNB today and so, it was really
in 1960 like
the Marriott or Hilton had started really
taking off, so it'
s this idea that we're the new way is kind
of true, but at
the same time it's what people were doing
for a really long
period of time.
I think for a period of time there was this
idea that
strangers were being connected from so many
different places
and there was this absence of trust and reputation
in any
kind of currency. I think finally all those
things came back
together and now you're seeing all these things
happen.
And it feels like it's a rich space for a
lot of different
types of startups actually to start popping
up which is why
we're seeing sort of the AirBNB of lots of
different types
of companies.
I just want to add one thing to that because
it's an
interesting point related to the fact that
this is how
things used to be. I think a lot of these
social businesses
can be proven out by entrepreneurs at an early
stage without
any technology at all, so one really interesting
example of
that is the Rent-a-Runway story where Jenn
and Jenny had
this idea to be the Netflix of kind of aspirational
dresses.
Instead of buying a $1500 dress, you can rent
that dress for
$100 through Rent-a-Way and they'll send it
to your house.
They had this idea coming out of Harvard Business
School and
when they met with us, we basically said,
"Prove it," and
they said "We'll have to hire all these engineers,
we have
to build this front end, we have to build
this back end,"
and we said, "No, no. Don't do that. You pick
the venue,"
but they decided to do it at sorority parties
at Yale,
Harvard, Princeton and they showed up at the
sorority
parties. In advance, they had sent out invitations
to rent
dresses.
They showed up with a small inventory of dresses
just to
test to see if people would pay money to rent
the dresses,
what would happen to a dress at a sorority
party, how it
came back, could it be re-used, lots of things
they learned
without any technology at all.
I think a lot of these social proof points
can really prove
it out, because I think the technology is
what lets it scale
massively but the technology is usually never
the business
in itself, so I think that was really an interesting
anecdote and I think it applies to a lot of
social commerce
businesses.
Yeah, we actually have a very similar story
with Chegg.
Chegg came from a pivot out of Craigslist
for colleges
basically and Facebook came out with Craigslist
and so we
were like, we can't really be Craigslist for
colleges
anymore. They had this idea everyone is exchanging
textbooks
on this site and so, let's try to pivot there.
Instead of creating a whole new site with
the Chegg brand on
it, they created a site called Textbookflix.
And then, what
we did was we got an Amazon prime count and
kids would come
in; I think we had 1000 students up first
quarter, come in,
try to rent a textbook. We'd buy it off of
Amazon and ship
it for free out to these students and they
would call and
say, "I just a box from Amazon," we're like,
"Yeah, just
send it back to us when you're done."
It was extraordinarily successful from that
perspective. We
got to test out exactly as was mentioned here
by Brett;
whether or not students would return the textbooks,
what
state did they return it in and being able
to test all that
hypothesis out before really even launching
the business was
extraordinarily valuable, so I think that's
very much true
for a lot of these types of businesses as
it was proven out
by AirBNB.
Another question that I'm going back to One
Kings Lane, it's
a little bit of a different type of business
with AirBNB but
I wanted to go back to this notion that you
were just
talking about how you would use your community
actually to
help inform some of the back end of your business,
and I
think that's a really interesting concept
because it feels
like social commerce then what you're saying
is not just
people coming and buying stuff, it's actually
some of the
information that they are providing you to
help you optimize
your business.
I'd love to hear a little bit more about that.
Sure. What One Kings Lane is trying to do
over the next year
or so is more of our merchandising and we
do it all
ourselves. It's beautiful, it's very expensive
to do, it
looks great, but we want our consumers to
do the
merchandising, so more user generated content
because I can
tell a story and I can paint a picture of
the room; if I can
get a consumer to do the same thing, it's
much more
powerful, it's much more authentic, it's much
more real. And
so, overtime the site will come more from
our consumers than
merchandise and the aspiration.
All the ideas will come from them because
consumers actually
have more trust in other consumers who share
like-minded
interests than they do in folks like us. They
love our
stuff, they trust people who are like them
and so, more and
more the look and the feel, the merchandise
that appears in
the site, the recommendations you name it,
will come from
our consumer base and we think that's very
powerful.
And again it goes back to the notion that
no one has really
cracked the notion of amazing content and
an amazing content
woven it together to provide context that
really inspires,
surprises and delights consumers and I think
that's the next
wave you're going to see and again, it's not
math. It's math
and editorial woven together and we think
the editorial from
our consumers is much more powerful.
Great. And then Brett, going back to then
the concept of
Groupon, it feels like there is just with
the wild success
of Groupon there has been billion other Groupon
clones that
have been born. How, as a company, do you
stay ahead of
that? Do you think that there is room for
everyone or as
there is more competition, does that create
problems for a
business like Groupon? How do you guys think
about that?
There has definitely been a lot of companies
that have
pivoted into this space whether they were
in it to begin
with and there are companies such Yelp or
even Google kind
of coming in and try to be in this space.
I think, to us,
that's a sort of flattery I guess in some
sense, because the
company has done so well. I think the thing
we hear from the
merchant standpoint that's very interesting
is that as a
merchant now locally, you get calls from countless
daily
deals sites all the time and so while some
of the fatigue on
the user standpoint for how many emails can
you actually
subscribe to, daily deal emails, there is
sort of a question
there. It doesn't take that long to read an
email.
On the merchant side, to engage with a salesperson
from ten
different daily deals sites, that can be really
tiring. I
think there is an interesting dynamic going
on where there
are maybe 100 copycat companies in the Bay
Area, they are
all calling on the same merchants we want
to work with and
that we have worked with. To a certain extent,
these
merchants they want to work with us because
they need new
customers, but they need to be dedicating
99% of their time
to running their business and making sure
that that's
profitable and making sure that that's running
well.
A daily deal site for them is a way to acquire
new customers
that are loyal, that come back in the door
time and time
again, but they can't spend too much time
working with us,
we need to make it really easy for them. And
so, I think the
more options there are for them, the more
actually it helps
us to a certain extent and more it helps some
of the leaders
in the space that have larger subscriber lists,
that are at
a greater scale than some of the people who
have looked at
the model and said, "That's so easy. I just
need to start
selling local businesses," and then quickly
learned while
there is a network in fact here, it's just
localized. It's
not the same network effect that's at play
at E-Bay, it's
all within San Francisco, it's all within
Palo Alto, it's
all within Chicago.
So I think there is some dynamics out there
that some people
talk about but don't really think through
all the way that I
think will contribute to having scale as an
advantage for us
across multiple marketplaces.
But if each merchant is getting 10-15 calls
from every other
coupon site, does that make it a race to the
bottom in terms
of margins for companies like yours or is
it one or two
survivors will really emerge in terms of we
have a big
subscriber and so therefore that's what we
offer?
I think the subscriber base is the key thing
there. For
them, again, I think that's it's more about
I want to be
able to get the right number of customers
in and in the
right cadence and it's less about the margin
itself. These
merchants are ones that again, they can operate,
they know
they operate good businesses, they know once
they get
someone in the door that they can convince
them to come back
in.
A lot of times, a very local merchant, so
it's not as much
like a Taco Bell where the person that's serving
them doesn'
t get to know that customer. They take pride
in every
customer that comes in their door. They want
to get to know
them, that's where that social aspect - it's
funny you were
mentioning how it used to be like - I think
in a lot of ways
what we do socially is we give these local
merchants the
ability to reconnect with their local consumers
in a way
that hasn't been seen in the United States
in a long time.
I lived in Spain for a year in 2004 and I
became a local at
a bar and I'd never done that in America,
I'd never gotten
to know someone that actually served me food
and gave me
drinks and we were friends and that's for
us the ultimate
success for Groupon, can we create that sort
of dynamic
through the internet, through mobile in local
basis?
Just to tie that all back, I think that this
social
discussion one massive barrier I think that
Groupon can have
at scale is that they can push social promotions
that are
curated because of your social graph and basically
drive
better the right consumers to right merchants
and the right
deals to right consumers in a way that once
you have that
scale upstarts can't do that well and I think
that's
definitely one really exciting thing about
once you hit
scale doing Groupon that other people can't
touch you, so I
don't know if you guys have been proven out
yet but I'm sure
you're working on it.
Data at scale in any business is a definite
advantage and
having the resources is to take that data
and figure out
what it means and then apply it to your product
then that's
something that we think about a lot, we put
a lot of effort
on.
Great. I wanted to gather some final thoughts
from each of
you on where do you think this all goes over
the next, let's
say, two to three years. It feels like social
commerce on
some levels has reached a maturity in terms
of what it
actually is but it feels like there is also
a lot more that
it can actually do and there is a big promise
aspect to
social commerce.
Before we turn it over to the audience for
questions I'd
love to get your perspectives on where this
is all going in
the next two, three years. Start with Brian.
I know a lot of entrepreneurs that they have
slide decks and
in our slide deck we had a make up a giant
guess on the
marketplace and we had to make a guess on
where this went
and I'm pretty sure that a lot of people now
have our logos
in their slide decks and they say, "I get
the Google alerts
for AirBNB and every so often you'll see AirBNB
for cars,
AirBNB for events, AirBNB for food, AirBNB
for tutoring," so
we've proven this model now which is really
interesting.
I think that now that we've proven this at
a certain scale,
it's really opened up people's, the door of
their
imagination to all the other ways you can
connect and I
really think it's all these different industries.
I think
for AirBNB, the one thing I can say with certainty
is that
it's going to grow quite significantly geographically.
Our
site was global from day one and the reason
we were global
and it's a very different than Groupon; we're
local but we
bring the locals together from around the
world. It's not an
in-store community.
Basically, we started in London, Paris, New
York. People
travel this cities from tens of thousands
cities around the
world and so this is natural that a network
effect that
happened where they came from these thousands
of cities
around the world, they booked, they stayed
in New York. When
they go back to wherever they came from and
we remarketed to
them essentially, that's all it was.
They would say, "You had a great experience.
You should rent
your place, you should tell other people about
it. Unless
your homeless, by definition you have space.
You can rent on
AirBNB." That was essentially what we had
said to them and
it really started to grow and so, I think
this is something
that's spreading internationally and even
with our platform,
it's spreading into different categories.
We see ourselves not limited to bedrooms or
even necessarily
houses. We have many people renting all different
types of
spaces. A few weird use cases that have been
facilitated
today are, when people first move to a city
now, AirBNB is
an incredibly common use case. Let's say you
had to go to DC
next week; you just found out you got a job
and you're not
finding an apartment on Craigslist from another
city through
a different Craigslist when you came in toward
the
apartments and you have to rush, that doesn't
really work.
People use AirBNB now for neighborhood sampling.
I want to
try out a neighborhood once a week and see
what it's like.
That's really, really common. And there is
a lot unexpected
things. People are even renting out other
people's homes for
dinner parties, which I thought was unbelievable.
It's like
why get a really nice house? Get a small house
and when you
want to impress somebody, rent a big house
for the night.
To some extent, I guess where I'm going is
we think that
platform allows people to project what they
want onto it, so
the future for AirBNB and for these marketplaces
is if we
create really dynamic platforms, people are
going to find
uses for it. They are going to realize I have
this. We never
thought that people would put up their entire
homes. We
never thought people would up tree houses.
One day a professor at Harvard decided he
would rent out his
house, he had a tree house in his backyard
that he probably
built for this kids. His kids went to college.
One day, he
decides to rent out his tree house. His tree
house is now
getting more booking than the house, and the
tree house has
paid for the mortgage on the house, so it's
pretty crazy.
When people rent out other people's houses,
do they lie
about it being their house or do they - what
is that
dialogue?
The dinner party one?
Yeah, the dinner party.
I have absolutely no idea about that one,
but I wouldn't be
surprised. It's actually a really good idea.
It's a great
way to impress a date.
Gregg -
The notion of maturity in social commerce,
I think it's so
early. I think e-commerce overall is really
early stages.
Right now, the share of e-commerce overall
retail is same as
the catalogue business which is somewhat embarrassing.
I
could say that because I've been in this business
for 10 -
12 years and I'm as much as a culprit as anybody
else and I
think this is just going to unlock things
that the internet
was supposed to do ten years ago.
If we think back, I was supposed to be able
to get
incredibly personalized experience for me,
for anyone in
this room as it relates to e-commerce. That
hasn't happened
and I think social empowering more people
to do that for
other people is going to really, really awaken
and help grow
e-commerce in new and different special way.
It's a lot
about giving up control and allowing consumers
and your
social graph to build your story for you,
so I think it's
early days and we're just getting started,
but not just
social commerce, the e-commerce is just getting
going in the
next couple of years. I think there is just
going to be
things happening that have not happened since
the early
2000s, so it's just an exciting time to be
in the space.
I couldn't agree more with those thoughts.
I think we're
definitely just at the very beginning of a
really exciting
phase, almost like asking the question, "What
is the future
of personal computing?" in 1980. It's just
stuff you can't
even dream about today and I think we spend
a lot of time
talking about AirBNB, One Kings Lane, Groupon,
which are all
immensely successful businesses but from a
venture
perspective we've been seeing different use
cases that are
equally social and commercial and they kind
of marry those
two in totally different applications.
Things like; I don't know how many people
are familiar with
just startups like fashiozine or go try it
one where you can
basically take a picture of yourself wearing
something and
because there is enough users on the site
you get instant
feedback on, yeah definitely buy that because
you're in the
dressing room at Macy's and that kind of social
feedback on
that one use case is just really interesting.
And so, I
think there is everything from personalized
closet and kind
of mobile devices enabling real time sharing
both with your
friends and to other people as you buy, just
we haven't seen
anyone really scratch the surface on that,
so I think it's
very, very exciting in the next three plus
years.
It's definitely new. I think there is two
dynamics we're
going to see expanding overtime. One is the
enriching of
that social dynamic; in AirBNB's case, what
are those
interesting interactions that are happening
when the person
is at that house and how do they make that
experience better
for both parties?
For Groupon, same thing. How do we make that
experience
better for each user and for each merchant?
And then the
second is really just mobile and I think you've
touched on
it. All the things that are coming out with
GPS, with
cameras, front and back; what are the things
that you can
build into your product or new sort of interactions
that are
made easier just by the fact that you have
this with you all
the time?
This is becoming the most important device,
the most
important technology that there is. If people
get nervous,
they get anxiety. If it's actually taken away
from them and
so, how can you use this device to actually
make things more
social? Those are really the two dynamics
I see.
Great. Well, thank you so much.
[Informal Talk]